Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie I'm going to explain
what's going on with this Batman Ben Affleck
news he's not going to direct he still doing
the movie though, there's a lot of craziness
that's happening, but just as a giant aspirin
pill to make everyone feel better.
I will be doing a new flash ring giveaway
tonight with my flash video so be sure to
subscribe to get that click that bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss anything I'll start
with the facts first, then I'll talk about
the rumors and then we'll talk a little bit
about Gotham at the end of this because they
just did some big Joker stuff, so if you don't
know the actual statement that Ben Affleck
really says there are certain characters who
hold a special place in the hearts of millions.
Just acknowledging the fandom Batman is one
of the most popular, comic book characters
of all time, he goes on performing this role
demands focus passion and the very best performance
that I can give it is become clear that I
cannot do both jobs talking about acting,
directing and writing the script to the level
that they require that when he says both jobs
he's actually doing three jobs.
So if you didn't know.
Previously he was writing the movie with Geoff
John's.
He was directing it and he was acting in an
there are very few actors they can actually
pull that off Mel Gibson doing Braveheart
is really good example of that that took a
long time to make if you want to see a Batman
movie in the next 10 years, and that requires
getting some help, so that's why Ben Affleck
is making the statement he says I've decided
to find a partner in a director who will collaborate
with me on this massive film I am still in
this and we are making it.
But we are currently looking for director
and I'll explain who they're looking for right
now and then he just reiterates that he's
looking forward to this he's committed to
it, bring it to the fans of the world.
So basically he's saying that he is getting
super burnt out trying to do everything that
you could possibly do like literally doing
every single job, so he's getting a little
bit of help to come in another a lot of rumors,
so I'll address those two and a second, but
the director was at the top of the list.
Right now the most likely candidate is Matt
Reeves the person who did war of the planet
of the apes.
So the looking for people that can do really
big tentpole films like this without letting
the characters get lost in the mix.
So what's happening here is that Ben Affleck
still has control of the project, so he's
looking for someone to collaborate with and
a lot of people like hey what about David
Fincher why can't we get him what about George
Miller he makes amazing movies.
It was a Justice league movie that he was
gonna make a long time ago before it fell
through.
But is amazing as some of those directors
are is a lot like the story of Edgar Wright's
version of ant Man if you remember way back
Edgar Wright had been hired to do the ant
Man movie from Marvel they tease it several
years ago there was some test footage that
was released and then what ended up happening
is is that he had trouble fitting it into
Kevin Feige's version of what he was looking
for in a marble film.
So in the last couple of years Marvel has
really reached out to talented up-and-coming
directors that is still very much Kevin Feige's
vision, so Ben Affleck and Geoff John's have
this really amazing vision for Batman and
what the going to do is try to find a director
can help them make their version of Batman
not somebody who come in and say I'm to do
it my way or am not can it do it all and that's
exactly who David Fincher is like their only
gonna make the version of the movie that they
want to make that academic somebody else's
movie and because it's Batman it's gonna be
Geoff Johnson, Ben Affleck's film.
So they're looking for a partner.
They're not looking for someone to make the
film by themselves.
So going back to the ant Man movie everybody
freaked out when Edgar Wright walked from
the project on like oh my God and man is dead
were never going to see it.
But then they hired Peyton read everyone's
like who is this guy we've never heard of
it he's never done a big movie like this in
the movie turned out great like were gonna
get the sequel to that ant Man and the wasp
relatively soon and phase 3 so this Batman
stuff is just one of those situations where
it sounds like there's a lot of crazy drama
it's being heightened behind-the-scenes, but
really it just Ben Affleck try not to burn
himself out before he actually has to act
as Batman.
A lot of you are also asking about the stuff
the Ben Affleck was saying last month like
if the script isn't good that I'm not can
it do it and it seems like he's not doing
it now in terms of directing like you still
acting it but what that actually means is
that it takes him a long time to write his
scripts.
It took him a long time to make Argo it took
him a long time to make live by night he acted
and directed in both of those movies.
So like I said at the beginning of this, if
you want to see a Batman movie in the next
10 years you have to bring in some people
to help move things along because any one
person can only do one or two things really
really well at the same time so they don't
want to wind up with like half of a good Batman
movie.
They want a really awesome Batman movie.
So now that Ben Affleck doesn't have to worry
about directing he can just focus on finishing
the script and delivering a really amazing
performance so the only thing is happening
here is that he just not doing every single
possible job that you could possibly do the
really good thing that that points to is that
the studio wants to start shooting the movie
in the next couple of months if you remember
it was rumored that they were going to release
it sometime during 2018.
Netiquette always get pushed to 2019.
Because it typically takes about 18 months
after they start shooting to actually release
a movie that just like an average number.
See you can see why the studio wants to start
shooting the movie sometime this year because
at the current pace Ben Affleck probably won't
finish getting ready till almost the end of
the year.
Many of the movie.
We get pushed even further.
So really, that's all that's going on.
If there any really big announcements about
the director that they hire I'm assuming that
it's probably going to be the war of the planet
of the apes person using when they say someone's
at the top of their list is because they're
finalizing contracts before they actually
start doing work on the movie the other big
rumor, I know a lot of you probably heard
about this is that because live by night didn't
perform the way the studio wanted to Ben Affleck.
It just sort of rethinking the way he approaches
projects that just goes back to the idea of
trying to do everything yourself and working
on multiple projects at the same time, which
is kind of what he's been doing, so I think
the studio is just like there's too much stuff
that you're trying to do.
So let's just have you do the really important
stuff will bring in a little bit help and
everything will be great.
So I don't think the studio pushed them out.
I think he just saw that he was going to go
crazy if you try to do every single thing
himself in it and what have like a mental
breakdown.
Even though that would be in keeping with
that man's character Batman goes pretty crazy
every once in a while but that's really all
that's going on with it.
It just sounds like it's worse than it actually
is because of all the political stuff that's
happening like we go on social media.
So many people are complaining about stuff
that's happening in real life right now that
it's hard to tell what's going on with the
really fun stuff that you would normally be
spending your time thinking about, so I highly
recommend that you watch the flash tonight
it will make you totally feel better about
life.
Humanity in general, Gypsies coming on.
I'll be doing a video for later.
A lot of you are also asking about Gotham
that was the video that I was originally going
to make for this huge Ben Affleck news drop
they introduced a more new 52 version of the
Joker than we've seen before is a lot tell
he is Jerome with full Joker.
They had some nice nods to the killing joke
with Bruce Wayne here and he even did some
very Batman things the like slowly inching
him towards his Batman persona he still a
very young version of the character but if
you guys have any requests for DC movie videos
just leave them in the comments below, there's
a lot of stuff is gonna be happening with
wonder woman in the next couple of months,
but because the movie doesn't come out till
June.
They haven't started their campaign yet.
Usually when campaigns are going on.
That's when you see all the footage dropping
everywhere when you see him make an all this
noise, so that will start happening, really
soon.
So hopefully everybody chills out a little
bit weird I'm a new episode of the flash tonight
I'll post my video later they'll be a new
round of the flash ring giveaway.
It'll be great while you guys wait for that
to post you can click here to learn how the
flash savitar the seer click here or what's
going on with all good news.
Thank you so much watching everybody thought
five I'll see you in the next video!